no he's eating it he's eating it whoa my
dude my dude oh they all want to eat it
hi I'm magarobi I forgot already
my name hi I'm nagar Robbie and I'm Ryan
Gosling from the new movie Barbie and
we're here with BuzzFeed to play with
puppies yeah we're gonna play with
puppies I'm nervous I've seen this show
before it's utter chaos
[Music]
oh boy
Here Comes Trouble
[Music]
it's so cute
puppies when you were younger I did not
did you I don't know how to lower the
register of my voice
I did but I wasn't like a Bobby fanatic
like I wasn't like a Barbie girl then I
had the Bobby foldout house which was
very exciting
oh my gosh well Greta wrote us into the
script so the script literally said like
Ken Ryan and Bobby Margo and you know
Ken simu and Bobby Isa so actually the
auditioning process for us was pretty
chill in trouble oh he just peed
yes because everyone seemed to wanna
whoa
oh no he's eating it oh no oh they all
want to eat it they all want to eat it
they all want to eat it now yes it was
very hard to keep the plot a secret
um because everyone was so excited about
a Barbie movie they just wanted to know
is that Krav Maga
go wig doing Bobby what does that look
like
yes everyone had questions and we just
had to keep it a secret but now it's
almost out and we can finally talk about
it
getting to work with Margo and Greta
yeah all these talented people
and getting to wear a fake mink and I
think the headband is a good look for me
I think you are liking that yeah I think
um
I think it
so sir
[Music]
I've been getting told for years that I
look like the girl from sex education
who is
and she plays one of the Barbies in the
movie pretty much because Greta and I
thought it would be funny
hey guys we were gonna do like this
whole joke about us looking similar and
how did you know this I did not know
this anyways and then once we like got
all dressed up as our Barbies we were
kind of like we don't actually look that
similar yeah like when she's got a brown
hair and I've got my blonde hair we
don't look that similar so we didn't put
that joke in the movies but when people
come up and say I loved you in sex
education I just say thank you thank you
so much
I've watched Snippets of a lot of
different things too in case it was
helpful
should we intervene seems personal do
they have beef what happened what
happened backstage bro hey dude my dude
my dude
please please my dude
the Ken thing is tough it's a bit like
that Pillsbury
um
go with me on this Cinnabon mix you know
like once you open that canister like it
all just it's very hard to
once you open it you're making you're
making Cinnabons you know and you're
loving it you are loving making
Cinnabons
doesn't it yeah because I don't know
what a Cinnabon is you don't know what a
Cinnabon is no what is it
[Music]
was so fun so we did a Barbie sleepover
at the beginning and
um
just wait for the leg sweep
always in the middle yeah we had a
Barbie sleepover for all the Barbies we
went to claridge's and Greta organized
it and we literally were like in our
pajamas playing games and ordering room
service the Ken's were invited to stop
by but obviously not allowed to sleep
over Ryan couldn't make it he didn't
want to sleep over anyway and uh so
instead he had other things to do he
sent a singing telegram
and yeah there was like a knock at the
door and everyone's like who's that
we're all here and I was like as a joke
I was like oh it's the stripper I
ordered and then when I opened the door
it's like sorry about the older guy and
it killed walked in and everyone was
like oh this is gonna be weird and I was
like no I was joking I didn't order a
stripper I don't know who this is and
then he um started doing the scene from
Braveheart and then he played on the
bagpipes and it was hilarious and then
we do movie church on Sundays so every
Sunday morning at the Notting Hill
electric we would play a movie that was
in some way related to Barbie or like a
reference for Greta for Barbie so we
might watch like his girl Friday because
it's like you know the rhythm of which
they talk or might watch The Red Shoes
for like
you know the colors
see and I knew you would do it if he's
in it he loves it though he's the
problem it's him
yeah anything small and valuable
seriously pretty much you know and the
memories yeah and good memories but yeah
if it's small and it's like you know if
it could easily fit in your pocket I
took my Harley Quinn back and jacket
it
yes have you seen jury duty yeah oh did
you love it
that seems like you don't well I don't I
don't I mean how's that guy is he okay I
was worried about him too but I also
follow him you know on my Finster and I
see that he's got a lot going on he gets
some bondage a lot of things and still
hangs out with like the rest of the
class I mean I don't know if you can
tell I'm a bit of a fan so I've been
yeah he seems he seems good a 90 Day
Fiance oh yeah you love that 90 Day
Fiance the other way
my mom would answer I think would be the
most solid but Eva's mom she's my
favorite person to FaceTime why yeah
she's got the face good chat and she
gives you the time I love that
foreign
was just like being a supportive friend
and having fun and I liked that what do
I do with this little agent of chaos no
don't let him go we live in a society
bro okay so you've gotta let me know oh
he's back
[Music]
um young Hercules
I can't believe
did you guys know that Ryan played young
Hercules yeah but we're both answering
questions so I've answered mine I was so
excited when I
when you revealed that and then I went
down like a whole internet rabbit hole
and kept
screen grabbing sending you pictures if
I know I was gonna end it open again I
hope people watch this and go back and
watch Young her Achilles or at the very
least I hope the opposite just that
little Ryan Gosling young Hercules
look at the puppies because it's amazing
what character are you I don't think I'm
like I'm not like any of my characters I
play I don't think oh
um so cool when you're actually more
like young Hercules
thank you for watching you can rescue
these puppies adopt these puppies at
Pacific Pup Rescue and you and you
should because they're really cute after
you've adopted a puppy from Pacific cups
you should go see Barbie in theaters
July 21st
[Music]
of course now they calm down